[Music]
the great one Mark Levin on fire earlier
tonight he's been warning about the deep
state and their battle against President
Trump take a look
the FBI sought to interfere in our
election I'm not talking about the men
and women who work at the FBI I'm
talking about the top echelon they
sought to interfere with our election
and they sought to interfere in our
election in worse ways than the Russians
did how is it the Barack Obama is never
questioned about this his name never
comes up
never comes up are you telling me that
the director of the National Security
Council Susan Rice didn't know a thing
are you telling me that the deputy
director of the National Security
Council Ben Rhodes a well known leaker
he didn't know a thing are you telling
me Valerie Jarrett didn't know a thing
as she sits there controlling every
department at every cabinet secretary
are you telling me that James Comey who
likes to meet with presidents and takes
memos that he didn't meet with the
president or take a write any memos it's
nice to see now that we have committees
of Congress who are concerned about this
it's nice to see now that we radio hosts
are concerned about this it's nice to
see that we now have television hosts
our concern about this where the hell
were they in March mark what are you
talking about where were they in March
when I had information pulled it
together from the public accounts and
began to pull the string and to see that
something didn't smell right something
didn't look right and the media came
down on me like a ton of bricks and mark
was on the show at that time in Sarah
quarter and John Solomon a March
they broke the story about FISA abuse
and a warrant at Trump Tower
it was reaction the author of the
bestseller trumped up how
criminalization no political differences
in dangers democracy Harvard
constitutional law professor Alan
Dershowitz sir good to see you again
let's I saw your comments that you fear
that they're going to try and set go
after obstruction of justice it was
supposed to be about collusion explain
your fear well my worry is that a
constitutional crisis could be started
if Muller starts
being the president's motives as to why
he exercised this constitutional
authority to fire Comey why he exercised
his constitutional authority in telling
Comey if he did to go easy on Flynn
those are actions that are definitely
provided for an article 2 of the
Constitution and prosecutors simply do
not have authority to probe the motives
and try to get into the brain of the
President any more than when President
Bush pardoned Caspar Weinberger to
prevent himself from being targeted
nobody thought to probe his mind of the
workings of his mind and so I think one
possibility is for the president to say
look I'll answer questions about
criminal conduct alleged criminal
conduct but I won't answer questions
about my motives in exercising my
constitutional authority and if you
press me on that we'll take that issue
up to the United States Supreme Court
we'll get that resolved before anybody
can be charged with anything relating to
obstruction of justice for exercising
constitutional rights in this
environment professor why would the
president ever go before Comey I'm sorry
before Mobe knowing about because he
instruct and page and what would you do
if you were his attorney
well first he really has no choice the
the sentian counsel can subpoena him to
go in front of the grand jury he can
refuse to answer specific questions
based on privilege or specific areas
based on his constitutional authority
but in general every American citizen
has to comply with a subpoena to go in
front of the grand jury and so he will
have to probably compromise and work out
a deal with time limits with his lawyer
present and with limits on the scope of
the questioning now they won't agree on
an obstruction of justice Muller will
insist on asking him questions and his
lawyers might very well say no that's
out of bounds it will create a
constitutional violation of checks and
balances and separation of powers for
anyone to question the president's
actions under article 2 of the
Constitution as long as they were lawful
actions under the Constitution nobody
has the authority to misschien the
president's motives all right so yeah
I'm sure look you're a well-known
criminal defense attorney harvard law
professor have you ever heard a of an
FBI director and an investigator writing
exoneration Draft after draft months
before they interview the key people
involved be when a phony dossier paid
for by one candidate is used not only to
lie to the American people that's
separate and apart but then used as the
basis for a FISA warrant isn't there a
strong argument here this never should
have happened
yes and I think every civil libertarian
should be concerned about the abuses the
FBI look I've been writing about the FBI
since J Edgar Hoover was the director
and civil libertarians whether they are
conservatives or liberals ought to be
concerned about the potential abuses of
intelligence which is why I call for an
independent commission a bipartisan
Commission not a political inquiry to
inquire into whether there was influence
in the election influence in the
election by Russia influence in the
election by the FBI or anyone else
because you're not going to get it when
you have partisan disputes by members of
Congress or a special counsel whose only
proper job is to investigate have you
ever seen it this bad I mean to use one
candidate a phony dossier they paid for
to be the premise of a of a FISA warrant
against an opposition candidate and then
an incoming president and then the FBI
director is literally exonerating so
this war and I believe there were crimes
committed you know miss handling of
classified information destruction of
classified information you know I don't
know many people that acid-wash their
hard drives and beat the crap out of
their mobile devices a professor so I
think there was a strong case it but
they exonerated or before they
investigated whether you know as you
know as you know much like what I know
is this but my question here is there
has to be a basis here that this was
formulated on false information from the
Gecko
look there are two issues I agree with
you completely that if the FISA warrant
was based on a questionable and possibly
false series of documents that under
Supreme Court doctrine can be challenged
the issue about whether or not you
exonerate before an investigation
depends on whether there is a crime
charge if there's no crime of course you
exonerate but if you're looking for
evidence then you have to have a full
investigation all right thank you
professor